[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
give me that horse he couldn't go on
or could you you're injured man let us
take you in the house
I got it going better get the Telegraph
Stace will take you Penelope
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry closed off the line I know but
this is urgent won't you only come out
of there you can't go against my
schedule goes out but can't you make
this one exception no what bring a light
with you you can't do this to me I won't
stand for it
Union Pacific won't stand for it night
prowling around here like this
you got your ball bust in my office who
do you think you are anyway my keys
pulled off the night well you can write
it but I won't send it anyway
here let me territorial recorders office
for Delancey help I'll corner steaks on
plots 234 235 chart 1089 recording my
name that's all how shall I sign quirt
Evans
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all seven sevens white ain't dead is he
no just knocked out that's great
emphasis what is done see a man not just
he's done he's done not anything I can
see I'm sure I ain't gonna touch it and
find out my makeup take it the wrong way
well when he and Wyatt Earp but deputies
over the tombstone to him shot it out
with a whole plant punch that's Bert
Evans
hmm he is quite a man of the girls sees
close the eyes of any a man nicer than a
woman would you call my father please
[Music]
where are we taking the wagon take him
home Obama my knowledge every indeed I
know it doesn't man right not day
that's pretty Evans help us like this
I've heard about you people how you
don't believe in guns or anything like
that only doing good so take my advice
you'll stay plenty far away from mr.
quirt Evans thank you very much for your
advice
good night
[Music]
so long cord quirt Evans is sure
something for Devon you know him y know
quirt Evans do I know word Evans want a
question that doesn't fly him I don't
know it will never get that bullet out
of him kicking around like that I'm
afraid to give him any more sedative
he's already had another the doctors do
you can't hear you what do you suppose
that delirious mind is searching for he
must be in great pain not with that much
laden are many more as if he were
reaching for something something
specific I don't understand it by now he
should be completely inert
or Thomas I was the young man delirious
I've done in this house Thomas they put
these back in the gun belt maybe we'll
have to get something in time down are
you crazy
it's empty well that was in a gun so
pretty it's stupid these wild ones I
keep picking bullets out of them and
setting their bones why it's their
destiny to wind up on Boot Hill no oh
[Music]
yeah
never speak evil huh well hit me some
more hot water young lady and start
patching him up for whatever's in store
for him
come on help me with this boat
mother hmm tell me again
what do you know about meeting father ha
they've heard that a thousand times he
was working on the roof of the new
meeting house he fell off I picked him
out of the dust and held her in my arms
he always said I hugged him before I
ever even knew his name and they both
know right away of course I knew he was
a peaceful man a member of the society
an evil man would seek the more
profitable way of life than being a
member of the Friends father
I should think that would scratch I
prefer a man clean shave you've got the
constitution of a mountain lion he'll
pull through
barring blood poisoning these wild ones
never seem to get blood poisoning though
it's common enough among the godly your
so-called atheists
always feel so compelled to stretch your
godlessness wash him bullets out he's in
no danger I bet he killed a lot of
people no II did how does he know that's
enough John friend doesn't speak of such
things
this is worth get that man out of here
but he's badly injured doctor this isn't
civilized Pennsylvania this is raw
frontier you must take a realistic
attitude this is a place where mayhem
theft and murder are the commonplace
instead of the unusual would that
justify leaving a wounded man to die
build your house by the side of the road
can be a friend man ye who believe I
don't mind your Maquis you've been a
good friend to us I'm glad I have a
logical mind and a good heart good night
doctor
[Music]
still having delirious spells keeps
mumbling about his past
I'm afraid he's had a very violent life
God how am I better on the black case
[Music]
you're in shape my husband you get real
confirmation you fill out that dress
just right right your color right me
chart 1089 1089 Margaret your noses I
just call it I got places to go on
country to put behind sure sure all
right violet
[Music]
by on demand
put your head on every here's to smoke
one so your hair is just like brown
yellow mixed up
just like corn silk
Oh gold-tone
[Music]
will you bring some hot for a penny near
the doctor says he's completely out of
danger just sleeping
you know dr. penny considers him her own
personal patient sit down and we'll
bring some milk dear and when you finish
you can go up and watch him while you
card your role on the loom he doesn't
need watching he's had no temperature
these past few days
dr. superlatively a healthy animal
restoring his depleted strength with
sleep he's no longer delirious of course
if you're determined to watch over him
penny perhaps you'd better take a pencil
and paper with you
his first conscious word should be
recorded they may be of great interest
to history or more possibly to a United
States Marshal who knows what violence
is involved with his battered frame and
his bullet holes would you care for a
doughnut doctor and not as much as they
should as heinous worth you can carry
this head-in-the-sand attitude just so
far in a world of reality let me get
this man out of your house I can dump
him in the establishment that passes for
a hotel in this off times dubious
community of ours in that unsanitary
hovel and he'll be off your hands but
he's much better off here of course he
is but who cares what happens to him we
do I don't
once when I was studying medicine in
Europe I had a friend an artist he drew
portraits of people and made them
resemble the animals they reminded him
of he'd have drawn this man as a coiled
Cobra Oh doctor your analogies terribly
imperfect and your naturalism faulted
Cobras don't cause tell the doctor
we're so fond of you and we respect you
so greatly we are sure that you will
finally realized that realism untempered
by sentiment and humanity is really just
a mean hard cold outlook on life a
frightened up I stand defeated and
furthermore there are times in this
house when I feel as if I were living in
a never Neverland but don't hesitate to
call on me anytime you need help
[Music]
[Music]
hello you're awake
sure I'm awake
what is always what where am i oh don't
you remember father and I drove you into
town
[Music]
anything wrong nope
[Music]
the doctor says you'll be all right
deleted
you're delirious you know two days and
two nights well maybe that's why I'm
something good either yearling steer
if I could catch one oh well we'll get
you something father Larry mother is
wait Oh easy
oh and he's hungry he's going to be
alright thanks a lot for housing your
work smoked sausage made sounds great
two eggs would you like like six you
shall have penny get one of fathers
shirts and a razor I'll get him some
food so I talked a lot yes I listened
only because I thought you might say
something that would aid us in helping
you as to notifying your wife for
instance what did I say if you had a
wife what did I talk about well you
talked of Margaret she she filled out a
red dress what else
oh you mentioned someone named Lila at
all if you have a wife we could notify
her no way
that's 12 I haven't been so flattered
since Madonna's won first prize at the
fair back in Pennsylvania must be smart
Pennsylvania some of the members thought
at an exhibition of pride to enter my
Donuts but what harm can there be in a
little donut
unless one eat so many of them if they
explode which is life they'd happen to
you young man
well there's worse ways of checking out
I'll help you but the dish no you stay
and watch quirt Evans I'm curious to
know the effect of six eggs a pound a
sausage and 12 Donuts I'll call it in
time for the milking well you people
from Pennsylvania talk like that
like what see we're friends friends of
foo Oh a society of friends many people
call this Quakers oh it's a religion
believe that on the wall each human
being has an integrity that can be heard
only by the act of that same human being
and not by the act of another human
being is that Quaker stuff you mean
nobody can hurt you but yourself
that's a friend's belief well supposing
somebody whacks you over the head with a
branding iron what that hurt physically
of course but in reality it would injure
only the person doing the act of force
or violence only the door can be heard
by a mean or evil act there very many
new Quakers very few sort of figured
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
morning gentlemen
morning carrot from a garden I found
these out in the road longer filling
named quirt Evans
I understand you're a friend of his that
made you see that he gets them back they
may arouse he gets them that quick it
lose his shirt it was [ __ ] Dom tell
us about everything I kept telling him
sooner or later
one second thought you can just tell me
where he is now take him on back to home
myself
where is quirt Evans you mean where is
he ever notice how a fellow keep
repeating the question when he's
strolling about answering yeah maybe if
I bend this gun over his head he'll quit
stalling well gentlemen I hardly know
QWERTY Oh
Eli's too you've been bragging all over
town with good friends you two are you
know this Phil ain't got many good
qualities has he sit down friend maybe
that'll help your memory I'm asking
about quirt Evans well all I know is
[Music]
thanks for sewing this shirt but I can't
find my pants get back in bed
laziness is the only thing that's kept
me there this long the doctor says you
to stay in bed four more days oh that's
no way to speak to an older person Joe
well we're pals you wouldn't expect a
pal that call me mister would you see
dr. Mann groups have to tell you some
men in tower looking for you says why
the men was a mr. Laredo Stevens in my
pants but your life
Johnny get me my pants no John will he
get my pants get the pants child but you
said said him more they use the familiar
and speaking to me the one unfamiliar
the plain language get me my pants they
said what about it well among us and our
used only the loved one to all others we
use you and he and they mother to
children husband arrived for children
between lovers of cars I'm sorry I'm not
what I'm not I wish NIDA speaks into me
[Music]
[Applause]
well I know right away that night this
must be a kind of a dull life I could
take you a lot of places I'd go what I'd
rather stay here with you but if you'd
rather go someplace else and I'll go
someplace else I sound very bold well
that's just that I didn't think
religious people were quite so sudden
and direct well that's the way I feel in
a be dishonest to say anything else yeah
I used to wonder about it I suppose
every girl does know boy about love
about whether as you got to know someone
you fell in love little by little earth
happened all at once the arch I wouldn't
say shocked exactly but you sure get to
the point
should I be different no penny I like
you just the way you are who emptied
this gun father weird that a gun is the
symbol of force
we never have one in our homes it was a
confession that father allowed even an
empty one was only because you couldn't
rest where are the cartridges at sign
[Music]
hey why don't we just busted because
busting through doors with quirt Evans
on the other side ain't my idea of a
healthy pastime tell him to come in come
in you can stand right there against the
light howdy quit you sure run a ring
around me all right
you know I don't think it was right
friendly of you to beat me to locating
that tract after my boys found it
of course I'm willing to listen to your
side of it I'm a reasonable man
sure Rosales means that's right the
biggest man in the territory you're the
biggest man in the territory Loretta saw
a lot of people say I hadn't heard you
nervous no Evans I can't figure out why
you keep stepping on my toes all the
time what's that's your business I'm a
good loser I like a good loser of course
I like any kind of a loser better than a
winner yeah you know I had a chance to
do a heap of thinking while I was
following your trail across the
territory I followed it but that string
of run out horses you left behind well
sir I figure it out this way quick don't
really want that land because work in
exactly in his life is in your line no
of course not I was getting it for
another fella and well I figure maybe
you sell I don't hear anything jingle
it's all right if I put my hand inside
my shirt why not
five thousand gold there
I want 20 well okay but I'll have to owe
you 15 that's all I got on me I got to
beat my pocket hey get it up know what
if the young lady could find us
something to sign this with still the
ratos hired boy a Hondo picking up after
him carryin matches free cigars you mind
yourself he'll mind himself
won't you miss would you mind taking us
over to mr. Evans please
thank you no I'm sure glad to see you up
and around for it
we heard you just flat on your back
sorry to disappoint you and you come on
over and get the rest of that money any
time any time that is it you feel able
I'll see you one of these days well left
so awkward
settle up my horse whether your kid
throw on my war bags what happened if
they knew the gun was empty it'd have
been Saturday night in Sioux City tie on
my slicker toe it's all right
oh no poor it knows none of our border
do you think I am you can't do that
we tend any wounded human and not for
pay you don't believe in force so you
can't force me to take it back I'm
afraid you're outwitted Thomas how long
have I been here almost three weeks and
I hate to get going
but you can't your leg you're in no
condition to travel don't worry your
cooking's got me grained up and ready
for a market
adios amigos
[Music]
shall I pack my things boy they'd leave
without me I got places to go
good I wouldn't care doesn't make any
difference to me how far I know it's a
little light I didn't know what could
happen to wanna not the other I thought
it always happened to both
[Music]
that isn't it is well done they do feel
it look penny I'm not that kind of a guy
that does things sudden oh yeah got a
look before idly you can ask anybody
they'll tell you that we're heavens is
unlighted cautious citizen oh then it's
just that you're not chewing it
yeah sorry please stay I'm sadly went
there's something I'd rather have in
this a favor
a big favor well you got them both what
is it did your eye patches with me
there's a lot of boy who don't believe I
know crit ever sure Oh God
everybody said you the fastest man in
the territory well there's those would
say I'm pretty slow and should be able
to do a good day's work after breakfast
like that see if you do it any first
bucket I declare a penny I don't know
what's happening funny thing about
pancakes I lose my appetite for that
first couple of dozen weren't very good
this morning too heavy wild Indian put
water on those vegetables this morning
ah we work around here Debbie done they
wanted to be a farmer didn't be anymore
Cheerilee you can walk to the barn
without that what I can't oh well it
balances me one legs longer than the
other you know the weight they are a
liar
throw the costume Hey
for I was 15 I learned to hate those
things I swore I'd leave ploughs and
pitchforks to farmers I'll do it
them all I'll do it but it's an occasion
why nothing just just thee
penny
well you wanted hey didn't you hmm
didn't they say wasn't this place
irrigated see all these plumes and
[ __ ] Fredrik Karlsen turn the water
on friendly cars friends who couldn't
make the golden we had built a community
damn what you doing about it don't tell
me your pride get any water what we
didn't pray for water we pray for her
Frederick Carson Carson turned off the
water and you prayed for him of course
can't you see by committing an evil act
the poor man injured his soul blood
there's a well because of it sure gets
birth to you around the earth we had to
wait for Carson go walk his pony nothing
[Applause]
you sure you don't leave no slack in
that cinch boss well sure how yeah this
ain't the first pony ever saddled he'd
squawk no matter how I done it you're
getting mean these days if he can tank
us by his natural born in that part of
his neck don't help him none either get
out of my way you belong behind a plow
[Applause]
who's Carson don't get down we gotta
take our no saddle tramps on this Fred
family are you deep I said get moving
[ __ ] nice damn yeah what's up to you
take out the top two planks what did you
say the top to let 16 inches of water
over there oh sure shall I do
who might you be when you're at home for
devan's well anybody might ride up here
and say that quirt Evans you know around
here by sight
anybody can say that him sure could does
a gooey stamp on his saddle well take
the top puncture the head gate you
stupid idiot
[Applause]
no I don't need all that extra water
step up on that for you know again
Victor ever done tell me what you told
me - you sure did step up on that pony
well it kind of Philip tries to get
along with everybody
beside me wait a minute ladies bear G
got a couple more of them played shutter
I got ten times as much water to need
that'll do for now
well if you ever need me more McDormand
all you got dude tato I figured that
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's start off from scratch you got
more water than you need that's right
work I mean for Evan do you mind if I
call you work out of it no it's no skin
off your moccasins if you let a little
water over that ditch I have to who know
Evan I mean port you're gonna be
neighborly or not well sure that's the
way to talk
[Music]
frederik cost my team is worth we always
knew you'd change your mind
yes ma'am I did Thank You Frederick all
of us here in the valley are grateful to
you worth it's like I was saying I ain't
got any useful at extra water why
shouldn't elect my neighbor use it
I believe that neighbors should be
friendly
you got there on your neck oh boy
there's word I arrest you're gonna hurt
me no that's a shame
[Applause]
well looks like your prayer is
straightened everything out so you think
you're gonna change Fredrick card who
says I pointed a gun I do well I didn't
and he gave him more easily and I
expected they remember this place the
Lord moves in mysterious manner of time
juicing strange methods of instance they
would be I I want you to have some of
these they're also good with coffee in
the morning makes me wonder the home and
shoot for Chinese you just come back for
more anytime you like they're always
plenty thanks goodbye goodbye goodbye
Frederick's goodbye man ought to see
more of his misery hey wonderful woman
that mrs. worth look she fixed my boy
hey excuse me I think father wants to
get drunk
oh you already thanked me I know I think
now we'd like to thank someone else who
am i plunder when I get aboard oh yeah
you know mrs. where it's going to keep
me supplied in pies I'm gonna bring her
over a quarter of beef now then why
didn't it come to an understanding with
my neighbors yes you're dead
oh well of course you know I was just
scared to death and I made that speech
them people I'm glad you made me do it
makes me feel good adios amigo
dinner
how bad dinner gonna be Oh roast venison
and vegetables and of course a skimpy
chicken well with a fine cake I'll try
to make out chicken or venison
oh I feel real good oh you do
mmm-hmm new dress oh it's first day you
call it funding course uh do me a favor
and you check the team your father sure
and will you do me another favor go for
a ride with where you're not to ask
that's a surprise
supplant hey I got a surprise for you
he knows I told thought you weren't
allowed to work on Sunday oh boy there's
nothing we're not allowed to do it it's
just that we don't believe in doing that
we know what's wrong
what makes it pretty much each fellas on
Jess know there's a lot of gents I
wouldn't want to give that much leeway
to
I didn't mean to frighten you miss
Israel sir full of named quirt Evans
around here yes I'll get it
never mind I can do more talking to you
it's been a long three weeks I guess he
didn't dare he didn't disappear for say
two days during that time did he know
hello you weather-beaten all hangman
penny this is wistful McLintock the
marshal of the territory harmless and
don't let that gray hair fool you he's a
curly wolf
hello quirt I thought I had you but have
fun tall fella fast with the gun held up
to Baker stage killed a couple you're
right tall and some say you're a fast
man but I guess I'll have to take the
little lady's word for it when are you
in Laredo Stevens gonna get around to
killing one another
oh right oh oh we water our horses out
of the same trough
well I'm sure looking forward to hanging
the survivor you know I'm a figuring man
sometimes I don't know all the answers
like that fella quirt Evans
handyman with a Colt while he was acting
as Wyatt Earp's deputy over the
tombstone one day turns in his badge and
starts build himself a nice cattle
spread suddenly sells out goes on a prod
why that's when I ain't free to jet
sometimes things connect about that time
fella called wall Dennis went down
infernal Laredo Stevens walk was reached
the Chairman some say that a gambler
standing there grabbed his hand
maybe that's connected how did you stand
with wall Dennis knowing two things
connected I know a lot of people well
I'll figure it out I usually do I'm
patient young lady don't be looking at
him with your eyes or punch out lighted
Cowboys there ain't no future so long
folks
quirt please stay away from the radio
Steve she owes me money and don't worry
I might come out on top
I'd be even worse worse gonna be worse
if he goes down and if I go down course
don't you see the whole be a guy with a
Mart stole don't make it sound so good
where'd you see why I couldn't love you
I almost look up Loretta it's better
this way
every time he opens the door every time
he hears footsteps coming around the
corner alright I'll start sweating
thinking that's me his food won't set
well the rest of his life
alright but if I'm gonna be holy I gotta
get some fun out of it
you know I feel like such a data buff it
seems hardly a whole week since last
first
[Music]
hey quiet I thought it was you oh well
look how long mr. Nam is worth miss
worth Randi McCall hi how are you - just
fine thank you
well well well you said that before we
don't want to keep you if you're in a
hurry I'm in no hurry I got no place to
go or we have would you care to come
along with us sure where to meeting to
meeting yes to meeting you don't want to
go do you be nice if you could we'd be
happy to have any friend of course you
would
that's just fine you know ma'am I sure
AM an old friend of courts why I
remember one time we were chosen cattle
down near the Llano River herd stampeded
quick pulled me right out from
underneath that no it's another time
remember and oboes fellas down in San
Antone we're late I know but I was a
wine if you can join us it's in the
grove just the other side of town
Thank You Man good day get along good
day
[Music]
I asked astound me concerning that
witch's brew one there is for his good
but if thou wouldst enter into life keep
the commandments
he saith unto Him which and God said
thou shalt not kill thou shalt not steal
thou shalt not bear false witness honor
thy father and thy mother and our shalt
love thy neighbor as thyself what comes
out of that thing that makes it worth
all as the work frozen pudding Oh penny
well Frank for Devin how do you do howdy
a mountains are horseshoer oh by the way
I brought the maple sugar you like so
much oh excuse me
I'll put it here thank you okay isn't
this the Morgan baby yes I - thank you -
cured limb fell it looks just like his
father
oh I'm coming out next week to shoe the
horses Oh fine I'll get some water here
let me help
and twirl this thing close and pudding
hold on I'm gonna quit I want some of
those flowers stick or something I don't
believe it it's a baby yeah I know is it
old enough to talk of course not hmm
well I can't talk it can't snitch well I
got something I think you'd like to hear
the radio Stephens is planning on a big
play he's gonna jump up some guys were
moving a trail herd up from the north I
figured that maybe you and me a couple
of friends could sorta play copycat and
you heard me didn't you you're gonna
have my part of it what am i listening
to you passing up a chance to blister
Laredo that's right what's your matter
with you word is formless oh the jame
sticking your head in this bucket I'll
shut you up
you know awful touchy lately you never
used to mind what I said oh hi come
along with the water clay shut up
[Music]
what would you come over here sit down I
have your attention friends we all know
the purpose of this meeting is threefold
as always to give thanks for the
goodness bestowed upon us but also to
give thanks for the particular that the
fields are again water and the props the
livestock thrive is too much for us
right at the head of the family just
take a look out there you can see a herd
coming for 10 minutes yeah whatever
friend
[Music]
we're happy to present you with this
token of our friendship for you
[Music]
this is Port Evans we're happy to have
him here with us because he provided
another incident which reaffirms our
belief that all men are good if they're
shown the light he persuaded Frederick
Carson to let down the water by showing
him that a man who is a friend to other
men is a happy man himself
I shake your hand with it
I want to talk to you
this'll sound like I'm butting into your
business and I am and you ought to give
me a watch with a gold case for doing it
you dim-witted nail bender marry that
girl
bury her well I assure you my intentions
I feel how would she know stop yammering
about shoeing horses that's no way to
talk to a girl talk to her about her and
marry her and do it quick hey come on
listen to this and ven Anaya
the son of Jehovah the son of a valiant
man of captio who had done many acts of
Valor slew two men of Moab and went down
and slew three lions in the midst of a
pit in the time of snow who three lions
and Benin nya slew an Egyptian who had a
sword he took away his sword and slew
him with his death I guess that must
mean a club oh brother this is good
writing let's go
what about the Bible you can't throw it
away that would be bad enough then keep
it all right it's just one book I'm sure
gonna read
I'd better take it back to the Morgan
why did put me so abruptly I don't know
[Music]
let's saddle up
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
hey quit what does forget mean I think I
hear ya let's get this stuff I don't
know how I missed this book you know
you're not very pretty but I like it
just the same when I cut of your head
works
what's nicer this way you making it know
anybody could just shoot these guys but
think of an interesting way of doing it
and you know would I hate to shoot
people remember eye shadow body once
Montanan I dreamed about it all the next
night and of course it's always
witnesses I can go to shoot the
witnesses stop jabbering and let's go
okay take it easy pal
it's your time you know no more banks
and again I figured change your mind
about shooting of Loretta was with these
guys step up on that horse
okay you've got it remember you're just
crowding were right I want to drone on
you in front of a lot of people kind of
saving him for a big night in town huh
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
gee I'm tired
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a horse like forever
yeah it's just who it is it's time we're
face to the eyes and she's wide open
those new boots and see if you can run
down
[Music]
you know this ship they may be a lot
fancier than wood sure don't give quick
action the truth I don't really like it
it's very fashionable
do you like island tickles going down
and it's expensive so I like it you
sleepy Tommy nope
tire toe worried or maybe just plain
bored not a chance baby you're never boy
I wish I had that in writing
you know it's been a long time since you
told me that my hair reminded you of
quartz okay their hair reminds me of
corn so old
Tony that's right all golden party
you're less romantic a lot more
absolutely take a turn at the wheel win
yourself a farm in Kansas I don't want a
farm in Kansas all right when you trip
around the world its Neil the customers
are waiting and that's no way to treat
customers
25 outing on the red Miss Dekker blues
[Music]
I love the way they change something
I've been looking all right buddy gonna
let it ride on or off for 17 - me
[Music]
[Applause]
bourbon large glass there's only a room
on either side do you have to come
bullying in here between us I didn't see
here you interrupted a very important
discussion on serious matters regarding
think things me and my brothers don't
like it
gentlemen gentlemen no trouble please we
just put the place back together after
the last difference of opinion gentlemen
what would the breakage in your bed they
need the break-ins I've had a dreadful
time keeping body and soul together what
I think is gonna happen happens around
out a full day there's your trip what's
eating you tall man did you have words
with those Baker brothers
oh those for my nose
no it's told around they're quarrelsome
citizens gentlemen let's consider the
incident closed watch our tempers maybe
I oughta go apologize
more whiskey be right back hope
well you back well Randy's always I'm
clean
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey later it's me
[Music]
I'm unfit the wrong man
firk sorry boys how you doing don't
worry about me come on you wait outside
and check them encounter with wheat for
all mouth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's gettin late
oh honey I was so afraid you'd get hurt
[Music]
we got money and whiskey and lovely
ladies just had a beautiful fight I tell
you we really ought to be thankful for
our Plus ah you've been reading that
Bible again something I never thought
I'd see what a Bible with your name
Clark Oh Randy stop there with what
where is he going if you forgotten
something
[Music]
penny what is wrong with the idli table
clothes don't belong in there I'm sorry
[Music]
unsettle my horse whether you kid sure
on a border for a while of course you're
always welcome
hello I haven't had a decent meal since
I left him chocolate not very good the
flour you know well I'll just stick
around you get one right I'll feed the
chicken really penny yes
help me Kurt
[Music]
does it take to to feed a few chickens
money at times remember you came back
yes why
I don't know exactly why did you go away
without saying anything
I don't know that exactly I think it was
because I frightened I know that sounds
strange that I should write you but I
mean it you were frightened because I'm
stupid
you thought that living with me would be
tiresome until after all
tiresome Adobe cos all I know race it's
a baby here on the farm is our belief
the people love Marion stay together
forever after this I'm not such a fool
not to know that outside worldly places
people love it it doesn't have to follow
that they married and stay together
friends I know that sometimes they
separate are you ever gonna run Donna
let me talk no court that's what you
were afraid of that I tie myself around
your neck and when you got tired you
couldn't be rid of and I made up my mind
if you came back so whatever you want
court you can be I go where you going I
go away they go
[Music]
I used to be an engine fighter
Jia's can't help walking up soft on
people one in Missy this young man been
doing any traveling since I was here
last fall over Casa Verde lost a big
herd a few days ago we're missing can't
got your tongue
Why ask her you know I've been traveling
you're looking at Carla thiol my horse
shaped up I did just that
you sure covered a lot of country he's a
right weary animal I just wanted to see
with the young lady life for you I was
going to bend over Casa Verde wait I've
been to rim rock and I got witnesses to
prove it
witnesses for instance Brandi McCall
Christine Taylor that's relate for
witnesses who else while in Neil I
suppose she'd make a good alibi witness
for you Randy Christine and Lila there's
three to draw to so while I saw you
there too huh yes
two million gherkin dollar and a half
brush jumper oh this is a mistake in
court that I'm patient that's what hangs
all you fellas in the end I'm patient
y-you talked about her whenever Tulare
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
her type I wish by here hers was like
corn silk uses
[Music]
[Music]
there's a sight I never thought I'd see
free diamonds behind the plow only walks
as soft as you do
I taught him well I figured you to hurt
him except you were thinking too hard I
think you've got some real important
business to attend to
someplace else sure but I always like to
keep track of your whereabouts
you know quit I always figured on using
a new rope and hanging you kind of
respected you you never took the best of
things and all your men went down
looking at you mind your own business
I usually do it's a shame things don't
always turn out the way they should now
that little girl should marry some young
fella who know what to do with that plop
why don't you kick up that horse and
move on some young fella raised a lot of
green cows sheep kids the kind of a full
of it she'd always know where he was I
have to run you off well now I'll tell
you I never have been run off no place
yet or aim to stay but it just so
happens I gotta be gone
no question you don't rate a new rope
with me
look there's a lot of foofaraw and
nonsense have to go with it I'm not
gonna stand for a lot of dressing up and
a fat [ __ ] jabbering people looking at
me just cause I'm getting married
boy come along well yes or no come on
picking blackberries all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think we have enough foot never did
like blackberries no I know I was right
it's too much work connected weather
I'll get some water
[Music]
look out there's a wasp unintentionally
well it's alright for you to trust wasps
and people but he might have known I
don't trust him and decide to take first
fight and incidentally that's not a
petunia that's a daisy
after that I tell you Daisy Daisy
platoon Cortez oh no I just like the
sound of it
why do you ever get such an odd name
fellow will have praised me gave it to
me he found me somewhere along the big
cattle trail folks had been bushwhacked
by Indians oh yes it was a big fella
cattle man it's one a wide loop in his
younger days I think wide know what
wasn't too careful who's Cathy through
his rope bet most of the old cattlemen
were like that he raised me it's quite a
guy his name was wall Dennis he was down
in a gambling place
well I grabbed his gun arm just as he
drew it's murder
stop it then what well I just bounced
around from place to place
quite
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I don't see any gun I know him he's got
a gun alright I know
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well what are we waiting for it nothing
I guess let's find us alone
[Music]
you don't have to be worried about penny
your mother oh I can't help worrying a
father
Johnny get that doctor burn up the road
both ways
[Music]
drink
it's amazing the Buried uses to which
men put alcohol to each different
individual it's either a stimulant a
depressant or an anodyne just now I'm
using it as an anode I get to the point
the practice of medicine is one of the
most infuriating professions known to
man it takes 30 years of experience to
teach you that in the final analysis
there's nothing to do but stand and
watch if she has a lucid moment you'd
better speak to her
I'm not trying to argue you out of
anything maybe you ought to stop and
think
she wouldn't like this quirt I'm not
arguing for or against her point of view
I know that to her the world's worst
tragedy would be that you should kill a
man of course you could argue logically
that she wouldn't know whether you
killed him or not I think she'd know any
discussion has to have at least two
participants of course if you refused to
answer me court I felt cynical this
would be a good opportunity to observe
that we're about to see a perfect
example of an eye for an eye etc
unfortunately I can't quote chapter and
verse I'm too tired to be cynical
but they are very ill he must not be
moving about mother I've got to go they
must get back into fare but he needs me
this is insanity I told you to keep her
in bed you want to commit suicide you
don't stay under those covers young lady
[Music]
there's no fever well they must do what
the doctor said mother please and
understand it I can't understand it at
all there must be some logical
scientific explanation I'm too old to
start believing in miracles
Reverend blankets
[Music]
the other two have had me covered I
never let that Hondo Jeffries pistol
with me rate upper Devin's hears about
this
Indian take the starch out of the whole
caboodle by quick me once well it was
Dodge City several years back when the
herbs and plants were done it well being
quirt come here mr. Evans
[Music]
alright Oh Stevens he's in the Eagle
that distal weapon handles with him take
him a message
[Music]
and buy the boys a drink celebrating for
why not but you ever get excited when
you make a big win like this where I get
excited sometimes you win and sometimes
you lose
[Music]
I ain't looking for trouble
just to carry on a message yeah what is
it
except they come out in the street is
waiting for you
who was this cord Evans what is this a
joke
where'd Evans's take a look out in the
street to see if it really is jack take
a look in the street
at all I'm wearing a black hat standing
at the blacksmith shop mind if I use the
backdoor peep peep
well if they're cats got nine lives cat
he also said he was curious to know how
much whiskey it would take to build up
your nerve to come out you're fixing to
get your ears pinned back the better
Perry airs out in the street if you want
to pin somebody's ears back here you
drink this sure I don't have to stand
there yeah come on I wonder if that
sharpshooting Marshalls around town oh I
saw him right out of town and ours oh
that's good
my name around here to split our play
yeah I bet that's just exactly how you
meant it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
great step away from those women
[Music]
why don't you turn around cord
[Music]
[Music]
doesn't ever work shot right I hate them
dead to rights
they've got the fakest stage so I
figured out what's the ruckus you down
them I'd hang you sort of killing three
Hawks with one stone
so to speak and nothing nothing ever
works out right that's a mischief didn't
work and I'm patient Tony a matter of
time and I hate you
I'm a mister from now on I'm a farmer
[Music]
that quirt hey quick might need that no
only a man who carries a kind of a needs
one
what are you gonna do with it hang it on
the wall in Morris with a new rule
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]